he's he's doing a great job calling
games on fox you're seeing him in studio
now
uh the usc trojan turned new york jet
you also uh spend a cup of coffee
philadelphia eagles and more
uh he's now here on the rich eisen show
to talk about everything going on in the
world of the nfl and he's calling
cardinals at niners late window 4 25 p.m
eastern on fox with kevin coogler and
the great laura oakman who's one of the
greatest people on planet earth mark
sanchez here on the richard show how are
you mark ritchie baby what's up man how
are we doing i'm great man life's good
for you
if i were any better it'd be against the
law i love it i love it dude
so um let's let's just jump right into
it here um and and and ask you what do
you think is going through jordan love's
mind
right now well i mean hopefully he'd
hopefully he doesn't test positive right
exactly
that would be the biggest deal there and
i mean what a you said it right before i
came on that what a crazy 72 hours we
felt like we pieces were starting to
fall in place and
we were expecting you know maybe a
couple big trades and they kind of
didn't happen we're expecting the desean
watson's sweepstakes to come to an end
and then
everything he didn't expect starts
happening with odell beckham with aaron
rodgers two staples in the nfl and i
know everybody's kind of reeling
reacting to stuff so the most important
thing for jordan love
is to try and compartmentalize and and
block out all that noise
get in prepare like he does and and you
know get ready to play on sunday knowing
you know he's going to get his first
start
and thankfully he's had a ton of time
he's had a ton of reps in the system
it's not like this is week one his
rookie year you know he's he's going to
benefit from
watching aaron play this last year and a
half
season and a half so
uh if he can just hone in on that focus
on those details i'm i'm sure that uh
now on the floor will get them ready to
roll i mean you've had many roles in
your time playing quarterback in the nfl
mark from you know franchise face and
hope of a city and and and two-time uh
championship game quarterback to
uh backup quarterback who you know had
to win games so how how difficult was it
for geno and cooper rush and mike white
and trevor simeon to do what they did
this past week
last weekend four dudes
all coming out with w's i believe
i mean that is unheard of and especially
it's different when you go into the week
knowing you're gonna play
but when you have to go in like when i
went in against houston uh when we're in
philly and foles goes down with the
shoulder injury back in whatever that
was 14 15 i can't remember but
you go in mid game and the first play we
called
was like a deep post and a deep cross i
mean this is like coming off the bench
cold shooting three-pointers
and
you're a little nervous like dang i i
could have used a couple more warm-up
throws uh you know i could have uh used
a full game plan and all the reps during
the week but at that point nobody cares
you know everybody's just expecting you
to play and play well and so we hit a
deep ball to macklin and i under threw
it a tick i think if i threw it
correct he would have walked in the end
zone but i under through and he got
tackled but at least we got the
completion so when you got to go in mid
game it's a little different than
getting the reps all week so jordan
jordan loves going to benefit from that
but it's funny too i was talking with
with coward yesterday and we talked
about mike white and i saw something on
twitter that said
the only other quarterback or mike
white's the first quarterback to throw
for 400 since vinnie testaveria i was
like dang who are all those scrubs in
between nah
come on now
come on now you're part of the ground
and pound mark come on now that's right
baby those are some of the best six
third and six line up with the fullback
and tailback and run power exactly
you know it's
it's kind of crazy dude and white is the
only quarterback who's thrown for 400
yards in his first career start um other
than cam newton that's it that's the
list it's unbelievable i would have
never thought cam would be in that stat
either that one blew me away well he he
came in as you know like a house of fire
you know iconic and entertaining as he
promised he would be and you know and
now
so uh you know uh
mark sanchez here on the rich eisen show
rich real quick mark you had a 369.
there you go in 2011 week three
there you go here we go
rookie here
[Laughter]
where'd you get that hot dog by the way
mark
okay so you see on the sidelines all the
time and these guys kind of like lurk in
the shadows but they're like ball boy
shagger kind of guys yeah
and they have the blue shorts and the
white shirt and a blue nfl hat
everything's got the logo it looks like
old school like
like central casting wardrobe for like
uh you know like a pe uniform you know
like so janky
and they're always on the sidelines
getting stuff filling up water and
gatorade and doing stuff and i couldn't
eat
before the game because we we win three
games to start the season we lose three
games and now i'm feeling like the heat
from new york and i'm like in this place
before the game where i can't even like
eat i'm just so anxious about the game
and
i don't eat before the game we have an
afternoon game on the west coast
and we i mean we just blew the doors off
we're up 38 nothing games in the bag and
i'm like dude i might faint i'm going to
freaking pass out i am so light-headed
and so hungry i need something and the
guy's like you got a gatorade we got a
gatorade bar like a powerball i'm like
dude i need like food food i'm like i'll
take a cheeseburger i'll take a hot dog
and go swimming run up to the concession
and i was like yeah anything but nachos
because i can't really eat that it's
going to get too messy right he goes all
right i'll get you a dog and i said grab
some mustard
so he runs back down hands me the dog
the mustard as promised and i'm trying
to hide that thing
and gumbel and deardorf
find it on their camera
and i was like so mad after because i
try to do such a good job of hiding that
thing and you know people some people
thought it was funny some people took it
like oh you know what a jerk like
rubbing it in like i could eat a hot dog
on the sideline which obviously wasn't
the point right and um you know if i was
doing that i wouldn't have hit it i
would have walked on the 50 yard line
and ate it like so so it was just yeah
that was it maybe they should cater give
me a hard time maybe if there was a blue
tent now that you just say hey just put
this thing up and you know cater it you
know let me do it right go down and you
know i was like
shoulder around i think i heard
something doc why don't you come in and
check it out you got a full bust
and bring some mustard and relish
and some cheese fries
mark sanchez here on the rich eisen show
um based on what you could tell what is
what what why wasn't o'dell working out
in cleveland
did you ever have you looked at any all
22 with that what do you got for me on
that
some of it is is just time on task like
he's been in and out of the lineup
baker's kind of been in and out of the
lineup and then i think this thing took
on a life of its own and then it became
something that they constantly had to
deal with
and
you know it's almost like when
when baker's
ready to throw and sometimes odell's not
there it was just like square peg round
hole and it just didn't work
and it was funny because i've been asked
that question like did you ever have
receivers like that and i was like you
know
i don't really remember that i mean i
remember guys being either really good
or just not that good and you're like
damn i i threw a great ball
that he should have been there or man
he's really fast i got to throw this
earlier i got to adjust to him a little
bit
but
i think they just missed they just
didn't quite work and like i said it
just became something
bigger than it needed to be and then
they're both
over compensating you know trying too
hard and sometimes when you do that just
like a player you can tell when they're
thinking too much they don't play fast
and
when you're not playing fast it's
because you don't know what to do
and you've got to go through it over and
over in your head and you just look slow
and it just doesn't work and so
unfortunately that was the case i think
you know honestly at the beginning of
the season it might have been the best
time to just hey let's see what we can
get for him but now they're just in a
weird spot where they might not get
anything for him and god forbid he goes
to somewhere else in the division
and comes back to bite him that's what
i'm saying i mean i don't know if he'd
wind up in pittsburgh cincinnati i think
is straightened but maybe the ravens
would say let's
let's go and stick him out there with
hollywood brown and
you know there'd be plenty of teams they
kicked the tires on him for sure just
all right we got to make a run you know
a team even even new orleans even teams
like hey if we got a ride with our
backup here
let's give them somebody else let's give
this defensive coordinator somebody else
to stay up all night on wednesday trying
to game plan for it well i mean like
just just to make it harder we all know
who would turn him back into a pro
bowler would be belichick you know it
like that's where everybody goes to get
turned back into pro bowlers i mean
everybody thinks that could be a great
landing spot too because of the culture
and the way he's handled everybody and
you know with odell certain guys um you
know the jalen ramsey's of the world
like different guy i mean when you say
like oh
you know they're
uh they're like people will use the word
trouble or uh problem guys or locker
room issues or whatever and i don't know
if that's totally fair right because
these guys aren't like
arrested every other week you know like
they're not in trouble with the law it's
just they're a little more outspoken
they express themselves a little
differently
and you got to deal with that stuff and
you got gotta manage
what you're willing to deal with in an
nfl
locker room and an nfl culture and if
you can handle it because of the
veterans you have
and other guys and then for them to you
know walk the line if they have to be
the company man in some ways if they
have to with some of their comments
and i think you know that compensation
on both sides
you know both sides can reap the benefit
of that so
um you know he he can go somewhere and
play really well and then unfortunately
it'll just make the browns look worse so
it's not a baker thing because you hear
that i mean you'd mention where you were
yesterday that's kind of a lair for that
sort of thing but you know is it a baker
thing mark
you know i'm still like
you're starting to see baker play
against a lot of his contemporaries and
i love his attitude i love you know his
work ethic i think he does want it to
work i just don't know if he's ever
going to crack that like
top 15 top 20
of quarterbacks in the nfl and that's
okay it's just
and that's what they've done with their
running game with their defense
players they've acquired the system they
run i mean it's heavy run now and and
when baker's been his best and i've said
this before
you know he's a 25 throw a game guy 30
max
and after that it's almost like a little
bit of speed wobbles it's almost like ah
this is not where we feel comfortable
now every once in a while you're gonna
have to put it up 40 times a game you're
just going to have to you're getting the
you know the brakes beat off you and and
you got to come back and rally from 14
17 points and you got to throw it
but if they had their trothers i would
say hey we're gonna run it you know
30 plus times and throw it 25 if we
absolutely have to
um that's just kind of been their
way for success and now they're in this
position like are we going to pay this
guy like all this
contemporary
nailed it no that's exactly that's the
issue right there because he was a 50 60
throw guy in winning the heisman you
know what i mean like we never ever when
baker came out of college thought well
this guy can't wing it around i mean
like that's the way he that's that's
what he did
here's my only thing now i i get it the
numbers are there but that's a lot of
quick you know rpo shallows slants
unders i mean that ain't like
you know going through one two and three
read you got you got better personnel 95
percent of the time in every game
different you know what i mean now you
get in the nfl
and you're like grinding out completions
on third and five where you got to be
incredibly accurate
precise with your throws
and one ball length left or right
is the difference between converting i
mean the margin for air is so much
smaller it's different than hey you know
toss a little bubble screen to cd lamb
and watch them go for it
and i'm not knocking it down you know
that's what college football has become
i'm not you know minimizing his success
he's one of the best ever play and he's
a heck of a quarterback it's just okay
in the ranks of he's
you know in the elite
class of quarterbacks in the world i
mean he's one of 32. so that's pretty
special but then you've got to start you
know divvying up okay well there's tom
brady's and aaron rodgers and all these
other guys like
you know there's a hierarchy to this
thing and i just don't see him in that
top 20 really before i let you go mark
sanchez uh while we're on the subject of
college football um how's the tomlin
contract did your alma mater working
how's that going i thought that was so
funny because carson mentioned it on the
air yeah and i remember hearing it and i
was like oh man
that's awesome like
dang i didn't even think about that
i'm like i'm kind of mad like i wanted
arson and liner and like all the other
guys got like an email and i'm pissed
that i didn't have my name on the list
right and so
i was like whoa that's pretty cool i
saw this
emphatic no in his press conference and
i was like ooh okay
so your all-time backfires
so who's on the wish list you know you
know who's on this
i i still think i think joe brady be
great i think um
man i wouldn't be shocked if this goes a
little bit longer this whole search
thing and i think they throw some
some serious consideration and money and
a whole you know
presentation at a lot of big time
coaches that are very established that
are well established right that would
like shock you like the you know the
savings and davos like people like that
just to make everybody say no
right just to make mike tomlin say no
just to make
i don't know sean payton like all these
guys uh andy reid like hey come to usc
here's what we got for you just to make
them say no
and then they land somewhere where they
think you know is appropriate but
i do think that i i think the position
sells itself i think with the new name
image likeness stuff
la sells itself
uh you want to work in broadcasting you
want to be you know a name in sports for
the rest of your life i mean where else
would you want to be
this is your spot and
um i think it'd be i think it'd be great
for for whoever comes in that stuff
sells itself
but the most important thing is they got
to get these recruits to stop leaving
california right they got to lock down
uh you know this poor poor usage of that
word lockdown not like code lockdown but
lock down the recruiting you know uh um
exodus from california because if you
keep all those guys you're competitive
right now
so um
i think that's the spot they're in but i
wouldn't be shocked if they throw uh
some serious money and some serious
consideration to people that are well
established that would shock people so
just to make them say no because it's
possible one of them says yeah why not
you know like that yeah why not hey what
else do you have for me let's check it
out hey let's go take a visit and boom
once you're here
i mean i don't know if you'd leave no i
know so there are so
you're saying there are boosters with
large enough checks
basically there's got to be about this
even though tomlin said there isn't one
for him
maybe not for tomlin
he's the man that was the funniest quote
i love your like you're checking your
spam filter for that email for all the
core like how did how did john david
booty get that email
you know
come on guys
wait a minute
oh all right mark have a great call uh i
look forward to hearing you call
cardinals at niners that's a pretty damn
big football game that's for sure we got
the rematch man we had the duel in the
desert earlier this year with trey
lance's first start so that was fun and
now we get the rematch with jimmy gq
fantastic look forward to that uh let's
do this more often mark sanchez it's
great to hear your voice you'd be well
i'd love to man
that's mark sanchez fox sports again
cardinals at niners late window 4 25 p.m
eastern on fox
he'll be in the mic
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here